I'm Danica Patrick and I accept the ALS  ice bucket challenge from Krissie Newman  very kind of you  hey honey take out all that frustration  oh gosh  you ready no 1 2 3  tonight Joe okay okay um that was  wonderful  but so said I don't like to be miserable  miserable by myself  I now nominate Ricky Stenhouse jr. Aaron  hall and Kelly Hall for the ice bucket  challenge and I have 3 ice buckets ready  to go are you ready would you like to  donate $100 sure let's take the  challenge  let's look like the challenge yeah how'd  everything this was coming yeah that's  why I don't have my photo apologize miss  what you had a feeling she's good  laughs I'm gonna I'm gonna do you're  gonna do my yep top you undo my wife  Chris you gonna do ready what colors you  want get down there let's get a group  photo okay he goes hey hey Mikey Ricky  that was a bad idea let go that was a  bad idea  nominations coming soon oh that's cool